il y a 300 personnes qui ont signé des
artistes à manifeste contre la réforme
de retraite selon Le Parisien 72% des
Français sont contre cette réforme je
voulais savoir si vous aviez signé vous
cette ce papier ou pas dans marie-clair
enfin qui est sorti ce manifeste et en
un mot ce que ça évoque pour vous c'est
ces retraites cette réforme alors j'ai
pas signé parce qu'à l'EHPAD on nous
interdit de signer quoi que ce soit
avant ils m'ont dit Gérard interdit vous
l'auriez signé donc je vais pas signé
est-ce que vous l'auriez signé je m'en
souviens pas est-ce que vous l'auriez si
la provinceau j'ai plus de mémoire
est-ce que vous l'auriez si non je ne
sais pas je sais pas du tout c'est très
confus et très compliqué alors juste on
rentre pas dans les détails est-ce que
vous l'auriez signé non focus je dirais
je ne sais pas
je vous offre une banane je suis sincère
vous l'auriez pas signé en fait il y a
un âge où les préoccupations ne sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes que quand on a 30
40 50 ans surtout sur la retraite moi je
suis à la retraite je suis allé un jour
en 2004 j'ai arrêté l'Institut aller
voir 51 en Yvelines un garçon vachement
gentil est-ce que je pourrais mettre à
la retraite lui ai-je demandé je parle
bien là et il m'a dit oh là là mais
largement donc j'avais beaucoup trop de
trimestres je n'ai pas je me suis mis à
la retraite
vous hein grosse retraite une retraite
suffisante pour vivre avec ma femme vous
savez ma femme et d'ouvrir elle mange
une banane
alors le poignet tu sais oui Gérard
c'est un vrai artiste n'essaye pas
d'aller sur l'oseille tu l'auras pas
intéressant Gérard c'est que vous dites
j'ai lu plein de choses je voulais la
vraie vérité vous dites sur un site
quand j'ai décidé d'arrêter au bout de
10 ans et je lis plein de papiers Gérard
a été viré de l'Institut au bout de 10
ans parce qu'on voulait rajeunir la
série c'est quoi la vérité ah non non on
la vérité d'abord c'est 12 ans 12 ans 12
années et ensuite j'ai commencé l'instit
j'avais 50 ans oui je m'en suis rendu
compte après c'est vous qui êtes parti
62 ans ah non non pas du tout non non
d'accord non non je raconte un peu votre
vie cinéma ça commence à cartonner vous
êtes nommé César du meilleur espoir
masculin ça cartonne pour vous je sais
pas pourquoi tout d'un coup ça s'arrête
un peu pendant un an vous travaillez
plus une et vous dites je vends tout je
pars en Auvergne s'arrête et là la magie
de la vie le téléphone sonne bonjour je
m'appelle Pierre Gamela j'aimerais vous
proposer un rôle dans la suite
exactement c'est exactement ce qui se
passe vous y allez et vous tournez c'est
un énorme succès aux eaux 12 ans 12 ans
on apprendra après que c'est François
Mitterrand qui a voulu qui a voulu cette
série c'est fou ça alors François
Mitterrand paraît-il dîner avec Roger
Roger
un déjeuner le lendemain on le sort au
lendemain avec Pierre grinbla et lui dit
le président a dit tu sais il y a rien
sur les instituteurs ce qui est vrai en
plus Mitterrand regardez paraît-il
beaucoup la télé et Roger donc dit un
diagramme là il lui dit il faut faire un
truc à l'époque le groupe socialiste on
va dire grimblin le président Bourges
vient de tout ça était vraiment soudé on
m'a appelé en Auvergne j'ai refermé le
scénario j'ai dit donc à Françoise ma
femme j'ai dit ça bienvenue c'est une
rente point de suspense voilà c'était
pour bloquer le Front national
je passe un petit peu court ranger la
banane
ah non derrière alors derrière il y a
aussi va savoir sur France 5 vous vous
amenez des enfants pour découvrir la
France et là on se dit vous devenez dans
la presse je dis monsieur parfait
c'est-à-dire le gars fait l'instit c'est
génial monsieur parfait sur 35 qui
s'occupe des enfants vous êtes décorés
de partout chevalier du Mérite
décorer vous avez tout presque une
pression c'est que vous vous dites je me
fais flasher à 200 alors sur l'autoroute
c'est c'est une horreur pour moi vous
êtes tellement monsieur parfait vous
avez une pression énorme non non mais
moi je sais déjà et mon entourage que je
ne suis pas parfait d'accord
je ne suis pas parfait dans la mesure où
je dors beaucoup et quand je veux donc
ça ça agace tout le monde c'est à dire
que c'est vrai le truc dans le truc dans
la vie il y a des gens qui ont la chance
c'est vrai de dormir et aussi je suis je
ne suis pas en colère c'est à dire que
je suis en colère contre personne c'est
vrai dans ce métier tout le monde le
sait vous le savez tous mieux que moi on
quelqu'un te fait vraiment des vacheries
là on est gros connard voilà et puis
c'est tout
il y a un moment c'est pas la peine
d'insister quoi j'ai une dernière
question après c'est pour vous vous avez
dit l'autre jour sur Télé le matin je
viens de noter ça vous dites j'ai 80 ans
et si je suis en vie c'est que j'arrête
de boire vous aviez un
vous étiez fêtard quand j'ai fait de la
radio allez vivre de la radio c'est très
différent oui j'ai picolé j'ai bu comme
un trou j'ai eu la chance de pas me tuer
en voiture j'ai eu la chance de pas être
malade mais il y a un moment c'est vrai
que Françoise qui est ma femme je parle
d'elle les choses se font sans le
vouloir t'es avec quelqu'un puis malgré
toi en fait tu arrêtes de picoler ouais
mais j'ai bien rigolé mais avec des gros
cons quoi de toute façon quand on picole
on picoler avec des gros cons alors
merci pour tous ceux qui vous regardent
on n'a jamais vu ensemble
ce que je viens de dire bien sûr mais
les gros cons sont sympas oui Déborah
aujourd'hui il y a plus de cons tout le
monde est intelligent pardon moi je
fréquentais des cons il y a plus de cons
il y a les gens sont intelligents
absolument personne et en regardant
quelques articles etc j'ai vu que le
producteur de la série de là il est très
dur il a dit la phrase dis la phrase je
l'ai plus alors vas-y
c'est un petit peu l'inverse de votre
personnage c'est un petit peu méchant il
dit exactement je vais y arriver de la
personne
j'ai tellement écrit
ah oui
vous étiez le le le
champ avec les enfants je sais plus la
phrase exacte il a dit il est l'inverse
de la série il n'est pas généreux il
n'est pas gentil il n'est pas c'est pas
là c'est pas quelqu'un de bien
il a décroché son téléphone pour
m'appeler en Auvergne en fait Pierre
Grimblat pour faire court ne voulait pas
de moi dans cette série ah il voulait
Steve ah oui
il a pas voulu donc grain de la a dit au
réalisateur
exactement à François Luciani c'est
François Luciani en fait je vous le dis
à vous tous qui a inventé la série
d'accord créer le personnage François un
homme intègre de gauche a fait cette
série pierre gravela là vous allez
savoir des trucs que personne ne sait il
a vraiment envoyé sur les roses d'accord
ta mère dit lui a dit d'accord et puis
François Mitterrand on fait l'instit
pierre c'est vrai pierre tu m'en voudras
pas à rappeler François d'accord et il
lui a dit
remontre moi ta merde on est d'accord on
est d'accord et là Luciani est arrivé
avec son premier épisode et le premier
épisode était parfait et il a fait un
site et donc
il voulait pas de moi il voulait il a
dit il a dit au lieu de chez nous
maintenant je veux pas Gérard c'est pas
un acteur c'est le plus beau compliment
qu'on puisse le faire c'est incroyable
quand même voilà moi j'ai fait un site
je suis pas acteur en plus des questions
alors c'est vrai cours
c'est quoi cette légende pose toujours
des questions en cours
[Rires]
j'ai toujours c'est une légende mais
j'ai toujours voulu savoir si c'était
vrai ou pas on dit que tu t'es fait
virer de RTL après avoir décidé comme ça
de faire l'émission entièrement en
anglais alors j'avais un petit conflit
avec un monsieur qui était directeur de
petites personnes on a quand même dit en
coulisse c'est un homme formidable il a
son petit caractère
je suis vachement gentil il y a des
moments il y a des gens qui te saoulent
quoi tu vois
tu vois il y a et en effet pour faire
chier tout le monde j'ai fait une
émission uniquement en anglais en
anglais en anglais en anglais donc
évidemment
je vais tout vous raconter quand même
Jean ferrator il est descendu de son
bureau de RTL à l'époque il m'a dit ça
va pas du tout j'ai dit quoi et il m'a
viré je suis monté dans son bureau et il
a fait une tirade très longue pour me
virer et à la fin de la tirade pour me
faire rire je lui ai dit excusez-moi
monsieur j'ai pas bien entendu j'ai pas
compris vous pourriez recommencer donc
vous êtes quand même je regrette pas du
tout vous êtes provocateur quand même
juste vous avez plein de tatouages j'ai
vu oui
ça c'est du vieux tatouage
[Applaudissements]
depuis toujours
[Rires]
précis et uniquement dans le noir parce
qu'elle n'a jamais vu ces tatouages
j'ai une question j'ai une question un
petit peu Gérard Jamel question méchant
mais j'ai le sentiment que vous nous
faites une petite Sardou en vieillisant
parce que quand je dis vous interviews
c'était un petit peu tout était mieux
avant les séries c'était mieux avant il
y avait plus de thunes vous dites jamais
je vous dis jamais la télé je regarde
que des plateformes quant aux séries
vous dites sur les séries c'est un truc
de prod de télé les meubles veut juste
les meufs les mecs pardon veulent juste
faire des tunes et c'est nul non mais
qu'est-ce qui vous pardon c'est vous là
non non non
je n'aime pas la télé
passons à moi ensemble
et vous verrez si je regarde la télé
non mais est-ce que vous trouvez est-ce
que vous trouvez que les séries sont à
la hauteur aujourd'hui tout ce que vous
voyez et même les séries je dirais les
deux mains nous appartient les
feuilletons évidemment et puis en fait
toutes ces séries font travailler des
gens des comédiens des comédiens des
techniciens c'est vachement important
quand même non non moi je regarde chez
cette regarder tout à la télé j'y arrive
pas évidemment ma femme ne regarde pas
la télé déjà c'est clair donc quand elle
est en Auvergne si moi je reste à Houdan
etc le matin je mets la télé moi je
regarde tac tac tac tac je fouille
partout oui attends juste une question
quelqu'un après je te jure c'est à toi
si on vous pose si on vous demander si
on vous proposez de rejoindre une série
aujourd'hui vous diriez oui ah ouais
bien sûr c'est vrai et moi aussi et si
c'est pas le rôle principal pas l'instit
mais un rôle non et alors moi j'avais
proposé de toute façon je connais
personne dans maintenant je vous connais
vous je suis content dans le métier de
faire un site à la retraite c'est cool
moi j'ai vieilli on reprend plein
d'images des autres épisodes qui fait
qu'au lieu de tourner 90 minutes ils ont
40 minutes à tourner le petit garçon il
a 30 ans tu lui dis tu te souviens quand
tu te battais dans la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme des rôles pour des gens 80 ans
est-ce que vous a proposé récemment bah
rien du tout moi j'habite à Oullins dans
les Yvelines le village où on passe les
vacances c'est Blaise mais le SL e dans
la Haute-Loire mais pourquoi le
téléphone là-bas
non mais je connais sincèrement le ce
qui se passe c'est que j'ai fait un 80
pages 80 ans un petit bouquin je suis
tellement bête que c'est un pote à moi
qui m'a dit oui ça fait 80 pages 80 ans
j'avais pas pensé parce que Frida donc
toujours cette petite fille de 10 ans je
disais quand tu auras 10 ans j'aurai 80
ans quand tu auras 20 ans j'aurai 90 ans
et les choses se sont enchaînés j'ai
fait un petit bouquin à contre d'auteur
en Auvergne dans une petite édition mais
dans le métier dans le showbiz je ne
connais personne vraiment dis-moi on
se connaît du moins c'est vrai il y a
quelque chose
il m'a fait un truc un jour formidable
ça va vraiment qui a sauté en dernière
minute et on avait une émission d'une
heure et demie et je lui en me dis que
de regarde ton carnet que tu pourrais
appeler et j'ai appelé Gérard comment
oublier oui il est venu il est venu il
m'a sauvé la mise en a fait 1h30
d'émission 1h30 d'émission sans personne
c'est long hein
je te le dis parce que je t'aime et en
direct tu parles beaucoup de toi en ce
moment beaucoup de beaucoup de toi ça
commence par moi qui le fait qu'est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux
[Rires]
la semaine prochaine avoir l'interview
people pour savoir comment tu es euh
quand tout ça cartonné
l'instit va savoir et tout on parlait
que de vous est-ce que vous avez eu ce
petit moment qu'on a tous eu enfin de
Grosset Porsche à bagnole pour boîte de
nuit oh ma femme femme auvergnate
ça se transmet non non non non non non
non on n'a pas eu ça vraiment pas moi
j'ai dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour
élever des vaches énormément d'argent
parce que j'ai commencé à 50 ans
donc je n'étais pas jeune agriculteur je
vous avais pas de prime non non c'est
vrai non non j'ai pas eu ça j'ai
rencontré Aznavour il y a très longtemps
moi je pourrais être votre grand-père
Charles Aznavour il y a longtemps
longtemps à la Maison de la Radio on
s'aimait bien et puis il m'aimait bien
puis garvarenz Georges qui était son
beau-frère qui faisait les musiques
venait à la Maison de la Radio j'avais
une émission je le racontais que des
conneries comme d'habitude et puis
j'aimais bien il y avait Nicoletta qui
commençait à chanter donc tout le monde
était là et genre je disais et donc il
se mettait au style white Superman tu
vois ok au piano
il était là Nicoletta chantait moi je me
faisais la gueule et puis un jour
Aznavour il m'a dit
écoute je vais te dire quelque chose
ne prend jamais la grosse tête j'ai dit
pourquoi
on dit ça il me dit parce qu'on dirait
que ça commence et je te jure que depuis
ce jour-là je me suis dit il avait
raison tranquille c'est bon vous a fait
une jogg à Gabin quand vous êtes arrivés
en Auvergne vous vouliez vraiment
avoir des vaches avoir tout ça et tout
et comme Jean Gabin vous n'avez jamais
été accepté par les paysans et moi je
voulais quand même dire parce que les
paysans étaient toujours ils nous
nourrissent ils sont adorables ils ont
les valeurs de la terre sauf que les
paysans n'ont pas que des qualités quand
on essaye nous aussi de faire des choses
et vous et ne nous accepte pas c'est
vrai je suis avoir un joker là pour
bien sûr comment vous appelez comment
vous appelez
le Juif de Vedrine
sympa
c'est quand même quelque chose ouais
mais c'est pour ça que dans la vie si on
veut vieillir aimablement il faut gommer
tout ça un soir on buvait un coup avec
des potes et avec des cons non avec des
chats
tu es pas en colère le camion du blanc
le blanc qui était qui bien le blanc ça
écarquille l'oeil alors doucement il y a
la télé
mais moi je gomme je leur disais et en
fait tu gommes il me disait mais tu
gommes et quand on gommes quand même sur
le papier il reste un mille mais c'est
tout petit alors je disais tu vois ils
sont foutu de ma gueule toute la soirée
et dans la vie des fois quand on gomme
et vous savez je veux pas être quelque
chose mais vous savez on dit toujours
qu'on a la tête en vieillissant de ce
qu'on est et vous êtes très beau donc
Gérard rêve encore et comme Gérard fais
jamais rien comme les autres en fait
c'est votre vie mais raconté en poésie
avec Frida qui me disait donc je disais
quand tu auras 10 ans etc j'ai fait une
toute petite chanson qui dit
ça pas facile d'avoir de vie il me
faudrait un siècle et demi etc et puis
après on se dit mais au fond je vais
faire un petit bouquin avec des
conneries et puis des chansonnettes j'ai
appelé Hugues Aufray qui est quand même
ça fait 60 ans que je le connais bien
sûr je vais raconter tout ça il est plus
bavarde que moi je vais raconter tout ça
il m'a dit bon alors tu vas faire un CD
ton vendras pas il m'a dit personne
n'avant à part un mec à cheveux longs
donc on rigolait mais il m'a dit fais-le
pour ta famille exactement et j'ai dit
ma famille c'est vous aussi c'est tous
les gens qui sont là et donc je l'ai
fait alors
je te donne 3 secondes pour te dire
est-ce que c'est une question qui vaut
vraiment le coup
parce qu'on est en train de se dire avec
Benoît vous êtes vachement bien pour 80
ans
si vous aviez fait un petit truc
ma mère elle est morte à 106 ans
que j'ai posé au début en fait parce que
je le vois physiquement il s'exprime
vachement bien il est vif
80 ans tu vas me dire moi j'aimerais
bien aller à 80 ans et d'être comme lui
Gérard était avec nous Gérard rêve
encore le gros dos tout de suite et les
people doctissent se mouiller ou se
taire merci encore Gérard merci à toi
merci à vous merci